i'm obviously incredibly excited
about um you know some other superhero
movie that might be coming up
i have no idea something with dwayne
johnson maybe
yeah man uh i am uh how
when you for a role like that how much
are they telling you about the arc of
the character and ultimately
what you'll be doing and how much is it
sort of like oh dwayne johnson's
superheroes dc yeah i'm in
yeah exactly uh so we we discuss
a lot about the arc of the character and
um
that's all i can say on that
right well i guess what i mean is though
do you know
ultimately like what they want you to do
in the dc universe
or is it sort of like you're just
signing on to this one thing
i the connection broke up i couldn't
hear i
you know oh man
you said something about the rock though
and yes
i'm sworn to secrecy but yeah working
with the rock man this is this is gonna
be awesome
uh man i i'm a real i'm a big fan of
of the moves he's made in his career and
how he got to where he's at i mean
to you got to be a smart brother and
i'm talking about a hustling brother to
to make it up to the top of the ranks to
become the biggest action star in the
world
and he's done so with really smart
strategic moves so i can't wait to just
kind of pick his brain on a couple of
things i already been asking about the
nutritional stuff
you got me set right there but um you
know
i like to surround myself with uh real
mavericks who are teachers and i feel
like being around
him i'll be able to to learn a little
bit of how to manage that hustle
just the way i learned a lot from you
know regina on this project in terms of
how she handled herself
as a leader on set being able to manage
the full team man it was a
fantastic education watching her work